[Music]
you worked on the movie trolls at Justin
Timberlake and then you got to make them
the music video with him you got to make
the song and the video for can't stop
the feeling is that right I got to go
back that's exciting
yeah I got to go to a studio I got to
meet him he smells so good
what's he what's he smell like money
that's a nice smell Ian's confidence the
studio is awesome it's just like there's
like a lot of platinum records from when
Beyonce orianna's record it there and
then there's just a lot of signs that
say no hoverboards allowed which is like
what's that story yeah you know
something went yet way wrong with a
hoverboard did he fall off the
hoverboard or did he see that Mike Tyson
video and he's like no never again now
you got to perform in the video what's
your dance style like oh did you have to
get any training or - jeez you're own so
no no no I'm self trained going out I
mean I can describe my style in two
words it's a staring and shoulders
staring and shoulders mm-hmm it's all
shoulder work back and forth and then I
stare out into the distance and that
brings all the nerd girls towards me I
mean I could show you yeah yeah
[Applause]
we need to got lead in with this
shoulder right then you pop it back you
reverse it and then you make a motion
and that's what draws the late is it and
the ladies
[Applause]
you